hey guys and welcome back to the layah heilpern
show as always it is powered by icon plus so
some really quick news for you
before i introduce a pretty exciting
guest so um very exciting news from icon and
the popular destination juju island the early
announced blockchain based covert id contact
tracing app that is using icons did technology
is now fully operational so some news as always
from icon there now i want to say thank you to
my sponsors block buy i use them to earn up to 8.6
interest on my usdc so that is pretty insane i'm
going to leave a link for you you can actually get
250 when you sign up so that is some incredible
passive income for you so i would definitely
recommend that i use that so they're a really
great um platform for you now before i bring on
my guests just a really quick thank you to um
coinflip so they are doing some incredible work
across the states to push bitcoin mass adoption
they now actually have 1422 bitcoin atms which
provide access to the everyday people so if you're
interested in getting some bitcoin then you can
get 10 off all your transactions i'll leave the
discount code for you now joining me today is a
major international new york times bestselling
author known for accidental billionaires and
bitcoin billionaires as well as many other
different stories so it is of course ben mezrich
ben great to have you how are you doing thank you
i'm doing great thanks for having me this is this
is fun so awesome yeah i'm really excited to chat
to you i'm a huge fan of the stories especially as
somebody um that's a bitcoiner i'm an absolute fan
so i want to kind of go back a little bit though
because you're obviously very well known um as a
journalist as a storyteller um you know from
the movie and the social network and all of
this stuff but can you sort of take talk to us
a little bit about you because who is ben how
did you how did you get into um journalism
how did you get into storytelling and also
how would you sort of define yourself yeah so i've
wanted to be a writer since i was a little kid
i was about 12 when i decided that's all i wanted
to do with my life i sold my first book right out
of college um it wasn't an easy process i was
rejected a lot i i was i had written uh locked
myself in an apartment and wrote uh nine books
the year i graduated from college which i don't
recommend to anyone but was rejected by everyone
in publishing i got about 190 rejections left
um and uh my first book came out nobody read it
and so i used to write medical thrillers um sci-fi
kind of stuff until i met the mit blackjack
team i started going to vegas with these guys
i was kind of blown away by it and i wrote a
book called bringing down the house which is
about these mit kids who took vegas for millions
of dollars it became the movie 21. and so i became
a journalist by accident i never intended to be
a fiction writer i wanted to just write thrillers
but that book took off so my next you know 15
books or whatever were true stories you know i'm
always looking for these revolutionary stories
about young people doing something really cool
um and late one night i got a weird email um from
a harvard senior who said my best friend founded
facebook and no one's ever heard of him and it was
eduardo saverin's roommate eduardo came to me and
um and that began the process of what became the
social network so that was a really an accident
as well these things have all kind of fallen in my
lap and uh and so i i describe myself as an author
as a writer it's always ever wanted to be um but i
i have a deep connection to hollywood so i usually
write you know i find a story i write a proposal
i sell it as a movie or a television show
then i write a book and um so i'm known as a book
writer but really i think my interests are both
you know visual and and in the book form and uh
and yeah i guess uh you know i'm i'm an eccentric
reclusive writer but uh but you know i love
that i fortunately found myself in the center of
multiple big stories um so um i always loved
michael crichton and i always my favorite thing
about him was the way he would sort of write a
story and suddenly everyone was talking about
that topic you know whatever it was and so
that's always what i've tried to do it's it's
find something that's really at the moment um that
it's you know the origin of something big and cool
um so you know every every book i want to be
about dinosaurs but you know there's only so many
dinosaurs in the world and so luckily i've found
you know winklevoss twins that's what's up yeah
it's been the same kind of thing yeah i
mean i think okay so firstly i absolutely um
i'm mind blown by the way you can sort of
say you became a journalist by accident
like that is that is insane you know like these
days you've got to you've got to get that degree
you've got to go to you know university wow like
you've got to get that there's a fair number of
critics that like the new york times who think
i'm not a journalist so let's be fair i did not
get the degree i don't have journalism degree i
i would be a very bad newspaper man um because
the important thing is the story it's the thrill
fun it's these heroes and it's not essentially the
little details that one has to to pay attention
to if one is a a real journalist so yeah i did
fall into true stories by accident never i wanted
to write thrillers i wanted to write sci-fi or or
you know da vinci code i wanted to write the
da vinci code and somehow i found true secret
things going on um you know bitcoin was one
of them but but the things that i found are
something the whole mainstream doesn't quite know
about yet um that's always what i'm looking for
yeah and i think um i mean this goes without
saying you absolutely smashed that um you know
from facebook to bitcoin it goes without saying
but you've had a pretty interesting week because
you caught the attention of one of the richest
actually apparently the richest man on earth elon
musk so you said that you wouldn't turn being um
you went turned down being paid in bitcoin again
so who did you turn down bitcoin from i don't know
what was it like to get that attention but so when
i wrote bitcoin billionaires i had an opportunity
to take the payment for the project in bitcoin um
you know it's funny as as a as a writer i'm
always the fly on the wall you know i sit there
and i watch and i listen and i and i tell people
stories and i'm writing about these incredible
revolutions that are going on um but weirdly i
always see myself as not part of it but someone
watching and detailing the story not that the
objective but real my reality is so warped to
me it's almost like this this movie that i'm
watching and then i'm retelling this movie
so of course i should have taken it in bitcoin i
knew i i you know did you know though did you know
i've been a believer in bitcoin you know
for a very long time and and the same way
with facebook you know i wrote the facebook story
before facebook was anything and i had nothing to
be a part of that and and i've done that in a lot
of places you know i've written books that have
made a lot of other people very wealthy um but
the thing is for me that's not really my job um
you know i need i need a financial advisor
to read my books and then tell me what to do
so yes i i i was on to bitcoin very early
of course there were people who were onto
it way earlier than me um you know bitcoin
billionaires came out bitcoin was at 3 000 a coin
um so you know of course had i taken into bitcoin
i'd be retired right now but but unfortunately
you'd still be writing i i became the objective
writer so it's interesting i'm kind of this like
bitcoin maximalist or whatever you want to call
it even though i personally have limited stake
in in how bitcoin actually does other than my
belief that you know the that i i'm supporting
people who are going to do incredibly well with
it and that in turn supports me um so it's not
like i'm disinterested bitcoin billionaires as a
book and as a movie rests on bitcoin being bigger
and bigger and bigger but um but i i've been a
believer for a long time i think it makes sense
i think it's smart i think it's you know it's
it's it's a currency but also a sort of value
that works in the world we're moving towards um so
i'm happy to see that it is getting there but um
but yeah i i'm unfortunately i i i turned down
uh opportunities to be much wealthier than i am
yeah i think i uh i think we i think we've all
done that we've all sort of made that mistake
at some point but i'm gonna get to sort of your
opinions on bitcoin and where you see it in a
bit but i want to talk about um the social
network and the accidental billionaires um
because like you said you received that really
weird sort of encrypted message from eduardo um
out of absolutely nowhere so just tell us what on
earth were you thinking um yeah go for it email
there's this guy named will mcmullen who was one
of eduardo's roommates at harvard this was 2009 i
would guess it was it was a while for those who
don't know who eduardo is just so if you bought
little network eduardo saverin is the is the
one who co-founded facebook and then mark
kicked him out of the company um eduardo ended
up suing for billions and billions of dollars
and called me so i didn't know this at the time
but eduardo had reached out to me in this sort
of machiavellian idea that he was in the midst
of suing zuckerberg who had cut him out entirely
um diluted into zero he wasn't even on the
masthead of facebook anymore um and he thought
if i could if he could talk to a writer it would
scare zuckerberg enough that zuckerberg would
pay him off and that's exactly what happened you
know he basically came to me and we spent you know
some months talking about it and i wrote a book
proposal so i wrote a 14-page book proposal which
i think i called face off i believe okay a movie
called face off anyways it was called face off
and my book proposal leaked onto the internet onto
a website called gawker.com if you remember gawker
and that day facebook settled with eduardo for
what became five billion dollars and on the top
of the settlement agreement it says you may
never speak to ben mesrick again because they
were hoping to just cut him off and cut me off and
make it not happen so he was five billion dollars
and disappeared to singapore never to be heard
from again and he cut off all contact with me
he should send me a gift basket i mean i got
only million dollars one billion yes you know
10 million in eduardo where are you eduardo one
million yeah but but in any event he got very
rich and he disappeared but i already had
enough to write the book and then i met the
lost twins so i reached out to them on facebook
of all places i you know knew they were part
of the story um and they were very generous
with their time and proceeded to sort of be
sources for what became the social network now
at the time they were the bad guys in the story
i saw them as kind of the bad guys they were
the big giant blonde guys who were chasing
the karate kid around the gym just the skeletons
right i mean that that's how i because i grew up
the 80s were a big part of my life and and to me
those are the 80s bad guys those are the guys in
every 80s movie who beat up the good guy so
that's how i saw them i didn't think much
beyond that i knew they were incredible athletes
i knew they had this incredible uh you know deep
like american belief in entrepreneurialism and
getting back up if you're down they don't lie
these are very honest guys which i think was very
intriguing in the whole social network they're the
only two people who don't ever lie um everyone
else is kind of duplicitous and you know there's
sean parker there's zuckerberg there's eduardo
but the the the winning austrians are straight
you know they they end up being the bad guys
because because they're so straight in a way
so yeah so i never thought i'd write about that
again i thought that was the end of that story
um until years later um so yeah i don't know
if you want me to go into the bitcoin store
i'll ask you no we'll get there but um just
at that moment though um did you realize
what facebook was right like like you said
you sort of stumbled onto two revolutions
facebook and bitcoin so you stumbled onto
facebook did you have any idea that it
was going to be facebook and also just not just
facebook but just like the beginning of something
so before watching me yeah my wife was on facebook
and that was about all i knew about it you know
pictures that i didn't know what was going
on and i was like what is this thing that
everyone's on i knew about it you know i had gone
to harvard so we'd hear you know everyone kind of
and stuff like that um but in the process of
talking to eduardo and then sean parker spent
a lot of time with shawn um with all these other
kind of insiders i i really started to believe
this was life-changing it wasn't just my speech
you know we're friends there or one of these other
things would come before facebook was going to
change the fabric of all of our lives now i also
believe that zuckerberg um was madeline michael he
was one of these people who would believe that we
should all be on facebook he didn't believe in
privacy he didn't believe that you should hide
things from other people because the world becomes
a better place if we share everything so he wanted
to turn the world into this facebook village
and there are dangers to that which we are now
seeing um but i really thought you know this is a
revolution this is life-changing this is a world
built you know for people who who don't want to
interact in person but want to interact online and
that's what we were moving towards so i did see it
as a revolution and that's why i wrote the book it
wasn't just a book about another company i never
saw it as that and i'll tell you what aaron when
aaron sorkin and fincher got involved i remember
when aaron sorkin told me the title is going
to be the social network and i thought that's a
horrible title i didn't think much of it um right
you know when you think about it it actually is
a really good title because the point is is that
this could be anything it didn't have to be a
specific company it didn't have to be you know
about a guy who makes a billion dollars the point
was this is the network that we now all live on
and that's kind of why that title works so well so
so yeah i did see it as a revolution at the time
but did you i mean you don't have to go into too
much detail on this but given what we've seen with
donald trump you know his sort of social media
band this week did you think ever that you that we
would get to that you'd be working on a platform
which or covering a platform which actually bans
the sitting president of the united states it's
been a wild run i will say i think with the social
network we got mark zuckerberg exactly right and
we got what facebook was going to become exactly
right um if anything you know i predicted that
we would all spend most of our days on facebook
at this point i really thought facebook i didn't
see twitter coming you know i uh facebook would be
the thing that where we where i thought it would
encompass all of that because i really felt like
he was creating a platform where you didn't
need to do anything else you didn't need to
have enough internet it was a whole silo that we
would all live inside of um interestingly enough
there are five of them or whatever um facebook
didn't swallow them all it tried and it swallowed
yeah that didn't swallow all of them but yeah you
know we are in a crazy moment where these things
are dangerous listen we you and i you as well we
live on twitter we live on facebook we use these
things because they're such a big part of how we
reach people and how we speak to people and how i
get my stories people pitch me things on twitter
all the time and it works for me but they're also
dangerous because they also bring out this sort
of dark underside of the world um where you know
people aren't responsible necessarily for what
they say or they do and that's dangerous um so
there needs to be a way to make people responsible
for what they say and do i love twitter but
the thing i hate about twitter is that nobody's
responsible for anything they say and that's not a
good thing um you know you should be able to
say what you want on twitter but there will be
ramifications to it and and that's that's not a
bad thing um so you know it's it's an interesting
it's an interesting world yeah i think it's
interesting what you say about facebook when you
say sort of wanted to be everything just because
in my opinion i actually think that's its downfall
um i think what twitter does really well is that
it just stays to one thing and i hate the fleets
um i think no it just needs to stay to
one thing just conversation in a niche
market and i think that's what it does well
yeah absolutely you know the simpler the better
for me that's how i use twitter i mean i never
really got into all the other magical things
that you can do with it but listen twitter is
world changing it's brilliant and and i think it
can be this incredible tool um we've seen it used
incredibly well so many ways but at the same time
there are dangers to it and i think that you know
we see that happen all the time as well so what
were your initial thoughts about mark zuckerberg
um he's sort of this controversial character
right well he doesn't like me very much let's put
it that way i i really wanted to interview him i
wanted to sit down with him and get rid directly
from him and he just refused i spent a year
um you know i got to sean parker who was a very
big source the winklevoss twins you know eduardo
all of these people around him but mark just
wouldn't talk to me he couldn't control what
was gonna write he was afraid because i was
talking to the winklevi that that you know i was
biased against him whatever um but i i think
he's an absolute genius i think he really
the power behind what facebook is and became i
don't think he sees the world the rest the way the
rest of us does i think he's very socially awkward
and strange i think he he's one of these people
who is happiest and most comfortable in front of a
computer screen and everything else you know is is
a delusion to him i think he's very much um this
regimented automaton i think he's a he's somewhat
a robot and i think to him friendships don't
mean the same thing they mean to everyone else at
least from eduardo's perspective eduardo thought
mark was his best friend i don't think mark ever
thought that about eduardo and so i think that
there's this disconnect between him and people
um which is a little scary when you think about
it but i also am amazed and and intrigued by him
i think he's incredible i'd happily write a mark
zuckerberg book if you want to come tell me his
story um the social network is is from the point
of view of eduardo i think i think more than it is
it's from the point of view of the people around
him and i think you can tell a very good true
story from the point of view of the people who
surround the story um not necessarily meeting
the man in the center um but it would be a very
different story told from mark's point of view
yeah i think that's really interesting i didn't
that didn't really occur to me um when i sort of
followed the story um that it was from eduardo's
perspective that's pretty interesting if you
read extra billionaires it's definitely more more
from eduardo's point of view yes it's a network i
think aaron sorkin worked very hard to tell it
from mark's point of view um so there that is
a very different perspective i think um but um
listen it's a great movie i i think it's it is
one of the best movies of the last 10 years and i
think uh it will remain that way um you know for
a while yeah so so bitcoin billionaire sort of
begins where this one finishes so can you tell
us where you first heard about what was going on
right like you have the winklevi which i still
find so funny that people call the wink of eye um
you have them sort of coming into all this money
going to silicon valley nobody wants to work but
then they go to ibiza like how did you even hear
about this story yeah so i i you know i was done
i didn't think i was going to write about the
winklevoss twins again they were perfectly nice
we got along great um they even came to the movie
premiere they were cool but um but i thought their
story was over bitcoin was something that people
had been pitching me blockchain and bitcoin
you know because i'm a writer in that world
but i was not interested yeah math and it was the
word blockchain i hate that word it's a terrible
word i don't write about bitcoin um and then i my
wife was reading the new york times and there was
an article and it that's the title the article
was bitcoin the the winklevoss twins are the
first bitcoin billionaires and i was like is this
possible how do these guys do this and so i called
and i went out to new york and i sat down with the
twins and i was like tell me what's going on here
and i was blown away by the idea that these guys
were at the forefront of two revolutions you don't
usually see that their story should have been over
um they got a payday out of facebook that you know
ended up being a lot of money um it was originally
67 million but they took it in stock and yes a
billion dollars and they smartly um you know uh
uh ended up in something else and and so as they
proceeded to tell me all about bitcoin and sort
of how they found it and why it was a revolution
i i began to see more and more that this was
something really important and significant
and the fact that they had bought so heavily you
know as many as 200 000 coins seven dollars a coin
um uh that it was going to be life-changing not
just for them but that they became part of the
story in such a very big way um and and and so i
dove in and uh over the course of a year with them
and following all the different you know charlie
shrim and all the different og's in the bitcoin
world that i could speak to um eric voorhees and
roger roger there and all these different people
uh i learned a lot and i i sort of you know
i'm not an expert in in any way like someone
who could actually do computer stuff but i think
i've become an expert in terms of what bitcoin is
and what it means and why it's important and
why it's significant and then that process
um yeah i became a believer um but as a writer for
me the important thing is this thriller this story
i would not have ever written about bitcoin if it
were not the winklevoss twins um because that's to
me what sells this story you know it's not europe
that there's a bunch of people who figured out a
way to make money better uh the story is these
guys who were the bad guys in the social network
fell into a whole other revolution and rode a
whole nother crazy drama to great success um
and that's fun and so that's that's why i wrote it
yeah so do you think it's a coincidence then that
you have these guys who you know are they they
come from a wealthy background you know they're at
harvard um but actually they're at the forefront
of two huge revolutions and i think actually
like i'm gonna predict this i'm gonna say
that facebook and bitcoin will be the two
biggest revolutions of the next decades to come um
just just because i think they set the foundation
right like something else bigger could come
along but like i think that will be a sort of
product of these two things so yeah i mean i think
you're probably right but i think you know i don't
think it's an accident or a coincidence that they
haven't been there twice i think it goes back to
who they are and you get that out but these are
guys who yes they do come from great wealth so
you could see them just riding off into the sunset
after facebook but these are guys who really feel
that they want to build something that they have
to prove something that they have to do something
great and that comes from their father and from
their background these are not guys who would ever
just sit around on a beach for a year these are
very intense people and that's kind of how they
come out as the bad guys in the social network
yeah it's real if you spend time with them they're
very intense and there's two of them so it's not
like you know you feel like they can do anything
and i think that they they set out to find a
revolution um they wanted to create something
great they felt like it was robbed they were
stolen um they believed that they were the
reason that facebook succeeded that they were the
people behind some of the smart things that made
facebook work and that mark stole it from them
that he cheated them that he lied and they weren't
going to sit down and let that happen they were
going to find another way to build something great
and so when they stumbled into bitcoin that's
what drove them to to be so crazy to take a risk
and to dive in headlong um so i don't think it's a
coincidence but you know they they managed to you
know find something great twice um and and that's
that's doesn't happen often so yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty it's pretty insane i think it's kind of one
of those things where it's kind of like i think
luck is just a manifestation of being incredibly
prepared you know of preparation so if you look
at it this way they were lucky to stumble
into bitcoin when it was seven dollars a coin
and you could say they were lucky to have the
money to buy that many coins but most people would
buy it seven dollars and sell at fourteen dollars
or exactly two dollars or a hundred dollars or
a thousand dollars or ten thousand dollars forty
the facebook shares you know so how do you hold it
all the way to here that's not luck anymore um
that's a belief in something that's doing your
research and deciding if this is the next big
thing um so a lot of us could have gotten lucky
and bought bitcoin and this is how i you know feel
better about myself i could have taken bitcoin at
3 000 and i would have sold it at 6 000. it's
very unlikely i would have had the guts to hold
it all the way to here um and most people didn't
um so you know it's it's uh you have to give it
to them they definitely believed a hundred percent
what they were doing so in the first one like we
said they were sort of the jocks they sort of came
across quite evil in the second you know we sort
of learn a bit more about them and we we like them
a bit more so how did they sort of take to that
portrayal of them in the first one and actually
you know they were i guess okay with it because
they were happy to go on and do the second i mean
listen they don't agree with all of that portrayal
fantastic army was emerging in it um and and they
i think they really you know they saw aspects of
themselves that definitely came out and to be
fair unless no one else was telling their story
um this was their story being told in a very big
way um and they had essentially been cut out of
history you know facebook was this huge thing and
they were being left behind um and both them and
eduardo saw this as their reckoning you know that
here we are but the winklevoss queens definitely
believed they were more than you know these guys
who were just rowing and eating in the dining hall
they felt like more guys who were doing something
great and mark sort of snuck in and stole it but i
think overall they love the social network they
believe that it was a true telling of the story
um you know i've seen them interviewed about it
and they they said it was a good good telling of
what happened that year um but they are much more
than that and i think that comes out later yeah
so if you sort of have to look back and and
sort of think you know all of all of this has
happened what are your thoughts then just on
i guess on all of it now because we we've seen
you know they've so i'm looking at i'm looking
at mark zuckerberg and i'm looking at the wink
winklevoss twins and sort of what they've done
and we've got the winklevoss twins with gemini
and then we've got um mark zuckerberg who's just
started well not just started but they're sort of
pushing with with libra yeah quite interesting so
it's really funny i believe that i've always said
this but i think zuckerberg wakes up every
morning thinking of the wink of lost twins
and i think that we can wake up every morning
thinking about zuckerberg they deny that they
say that's not true but i feel like that there's
this shakespearean drama between these people
that they're locked into this massive battle that
goes on for decades there's no way in my mind that
zuckerberg does not know about gemini and the wink
of austrians in bitcoin i mean come on and then he
launches his own coin called libra there's no way
that's a coincidence okay it's just a it's a weird
thing going on i think that zuckerberg is looking
at crypto he has to be i mean everybody in the
industry is looking at crypto and he wants part
of it he knows it's something that they missed
most of silicon valley missed it
they just didn't see this happening
and the lost twins did and so in a lot of
ways what's really cool about the story
is it's flipped on its head you know facebook was
the revolution and the wink of oz twins were the
establishment and now league of lost twins are
the revolution and facebook is the establishment
i mean you can't ask for more storytelling than
that um perfect kind of situation but yeah i
don't think zuckerberg's going to leave it alone
and i think we're going to see them move into
crypto in a big way yeah it it it's pretty insane
um because i think you're absolutely right in
terms of like that flip um flip on its head that
that flip on it on the establishment but then what
are your thoughts on sort of just facebook right
now i guess because a lot of people and in my
opinion i sort of feel like it's declining like i
don't use facebook i'm actually going to delete it
um i just i actually don't know how to
delete it that's the only reason why
but we haven't moved on and we're all on
instagram though so it's like you know
yeah yeah i mean what's the difference instagram
is essentially overtaking i think facebook at
least in a generation that's going on now in in
terms of the importance to their life but it's
still facebook i don't i don't see a distinction
between facebook and instagram so if you're gonna
include instagram in that no i don't think it's
losing any power over the over the younger people
i think facebook as itself feels clunky now it
feels too slow it feels you know dirty there's
all these crazy you know political stuff going
on there's fake stuff going on but i still use
it in terms of looking at memories and pictures i
think that's the fun part about facebook right now
but i don't really use it to communicate so
much um i don't use it as i did maybe seven
years ago right but i use instagram way more
than i would have thought a year ago because
it's a fun quick it's more streamlined it seems
more what facebook was um but yeah in terms of
facebook itself i could foresee it becoming less
and less the important part of the giant you know
thing that's nominating our lives but it doesn't
really matter to me what format is it's all the
same it's the social network it's the idea that
we're on this internet based society now um
um so there will be better and better forms
of it um but i think we're all still part of
it i don't think you're gonna get away from
it by deleting facebook i was watching um i
was watching a netflix documentary about social
networking and all this stuff and they have um
they have actual ethical positions right
like so you know how you have like um
like an officer for like diversity and gender
and all this stuff like they now have like
the ethics right social media so you've got to
give me your take what do you think is going on
because you know it's it's addictive um that you
know it's the the privacy and the data issues um
there are a lot of ethical issues so what's your
take yeah i mean i think that facebook really uh
it became dangerous simply because they worked
very hard to make sure it's a part of all our
lives and important to do that they had to
find tricky ways to get us all addicted to it
and they had to study ways of getting us more and
more addicted to it and then the fact that they
make money off of our data and it really leads to
these enormous ethical issues about privacy and
things like that and as generations come up they
care less and less about privacy because of it
i think young people don't care about privacy
so much they want to put things on instagram and
facebook you know they put themselves in front of
their house on facebook on instagram all the time
not thinking about what information that gives
away because and i do too listen because we want
to share we want we all want to be you know in
front of everyone we know it's just we're social
animals and then in the covid situation we see
it more and more people want connection so badly
that they're willing to put all their data up and
then places like facebook monetize it which is the
scary part um so there are huge ethical questions
and issues that come to something like this
um but putting that aside i don't think this
is a bad thing i think the idea that facebook
started with and then mark started with was
not bad i don't think he would rule the world
as an evil emperor i think you really believe the
world is a better place if we're one big village
if we all you know if you know the person who
lives in another country personally on facebook
that makes you closer to them and less likely to
fight with them right in a way it does work you do
have a happier world that we can all connect i
think that's all true so the question is how do
we have a happier world that we all connect in
knowing that there's all these bad people in it
knowing that there's all these people who have
nefarious reasons to want to connect or people
who want to make money off of connecting or
all these different things how do you work
with that and so these are big difficult ethical
questions that have to be answered and i think as
facebook grew that wasn't their goal answering
these ethical questions the only goal was grow
how do we grow and grow and grow now they're
going to have to look back and say okay you
can't do this we shouldn't do this you know and
so i think it's okay that they're hiring people
to sort of look into this i think it's possible
regulation self-regulation is is better than
outside regulation but self-regulation is being
proven not to work so you really need to find
ways that to regulate this stuff in a way to
make it healthy um and to make it happy but i
don't have the answers look if you look at what's
going on with politics and parlor and twitter
and there's no good answer to all this sort
of thing there are answers and some people
are going to hate those answers and some people
aren't i mean you shouldn't use twitter to foment
you know negative things violence and
revolution and all that kind of stuff
but on the other hand you should be able
to use twitter to state your opinions
so how do you how do you how do you police that
and that's not an easy thing i don't think there's
an easy way to look at it yeah i think it's a
topic that you can just speak about for ages um
you know especially given everything that's going
on right now but i think the biggest thing which
not forget like the d platforming of the bloody
you know president of the united states the
sitting president forget that um despite the tweet
that he was uh the platform for not actually being
something which incited violence at all um facts
um i think what kind of got me though was the um
the kind the the destruction of parlor like
that got me because it's an interesting thing
but here's the thing and i i have mixed feelings
about all this i'm not going to be on one side or
the other and i know there's going to be people
who are angry on both sides if i say something in
the middle but you know listen i think we need to
live in a better world we should be kind and great
to each other and nice to each other all
the time and all that this device that
needs to go away so how do we get there the end
goal okay the end goal shouldn't be a party or
politics or a point of view the end goal should
be everyone's happy and no one hurts anybody
that's the only goal we should be working towards
so the question is how do you get to that goal
and if you think your way of getting to that goal
is the right way then you should put that forward
but if you think your goal your way of
getting that goal that goal isn't important
then i don't know how we have a conversation the
goal is only a better happier safer world and so
for me you know i look at the parlor situation and
yeah i mean there's monopolistic things going on
and they're trashing stuff like this to try and
but what's the goal you know and that's what you
have to keep in mind i'm not saying it's right but
i'm just saying we have to keep one goal in mind
and so i don't know enough about parlor to make
a decision about what was going on on there i i
haven't been on them um so you know listen people
should be able to put their points of views up um
but there needs to be policing a point of view i
really don't believe that free speech reaches the
point where you can say i want to kill somebody it
just doesn't you know why if people can say things
like that then the world is worse uh so okay let's
make the world better you shouldn't be able to say
anything you want i really don't think that's what
free speech is all about you really shouldn't you
can't say hateful things and if you're willing to
say hateful things people should be allowed to not
listen to you and if there's a way of doing
that um we should do it so i'm not a fan of
of violent hate speech i don't think i ever will
be and i don't think someone can convince me
that we should be a fan of violent hate speech
i'm not saying parlor is that i don't know enough
about parlor but i can be a reason why we don't
want to foment violent hate space i mean i think
that's something we should endeavor self-endeavor
i think self-regulation is the way to do it 100
i think people should look at themselves and say
okay this is a hateful violent thing to say so
i'm not going to say it but there are always going
to be people who are always going to say hateful
violent things right so what do we do about that
do we just let them say hateful violent things
i mean i think you're a true libertarian and
you don't care what the world looks like you
say everyone say anything you want but i don't
want that world i i don't want my kids to grow
up in a world where people around them
are just saying hateful violent things
because they have free speech do you when you're
kids at school do you want the person next to them
to be saying hateful violent things because they
have the freedom to i mean you don't you don't
want your kids sitting next to someone saying that
right so why are you okay with it on the internet
so i okay so i think school is a little different
but i think i think the problem the problem with
with sort of policing speech and i'm a huge fan of
jordan peterson jordan peterson to me is just like
an idol like i'm in awe of everything he has
to say i can't fault him in the slightest but
he talks a lot about sort of looking
at speech and sort of understanding um
you there's hate and there's violence
right so that they're two different things
and i think how how you know what might be hateful
to you may not be hateful to somebody else what
might be offensive to you may not be defensive
you're absolutely right but in reality no
i think in reality we kind of know what hates
it it's like pornography you know what it is
when you see it you know yeah you see it and we
can play the the literal you know the linguistic
game all the time and say well to someone who
you know lives there that's not so hateful
but the reality is you know it when you see it
and and well i think it's i think it's objective
when you're committing a crime you know when
you're committing a crime and i believe deep down
that the people saying hateful things no they're
saying hateful things they know it but they say it
because they want to i think there's a percentage
of people that are just bad let's be honest
and the problem with the libertarian
point of view and i i am a libertarian
but the problem with the libertarian point of
view is that there are very bad people out there
so you can't just they're bad on the other side
as well like i think there are bad people on both
sides so yes it has to be equitable 100 i think
there's plenty of things that both sides i'm not
liberal and i'm not on the left i think there are
plenty of things on both sides that are hateful
horrible things and should be pleased i just don't
believe in the free-for-all i really don't and and
i believe in freedom you know to an extent but
but violence and hate are just not good things
and there should be a way to stop them but i agree
i'm not the person who could make that decision
and that's where we get into problems who makes
that decision how do you make that decision and
we aren't at a point where we have an objective
way of doing that so i'm i agree with you 100
that de-platforming people left and right is a
very dangerous thing because god only knows who's
who's making the decision how they're making those
decisions but i do agree that there are people who
should be de-platformed so that's where we differ
i think that de-platforming the way it's done
is is not inequitable and it can be very dangerous
but i do believe there are people who should not
be speaking and that's that's that's the way i
look at the world a small percentage of people
should not have freedom of speech because they're
bad people and how do you pick those bad people
out i'm not saying they're on withside or
on that side but we all know that they exist
right yeah i i think often like that line gets
blurred and i'm very much of the opinion sort
of when you give an inch they take a mile and
that's exactly what we see on twitter because um
i've seen a lot of people being sort of banned
for misgendering somebody by accident right now
and i agree with you 100 stupid and you know what
listen i i'm not a fan of this this like canceling
people for statement theology i mean come on i'm a
writer i'm a journalist i think people should put
their ideas out there tell stories i think it's
disgusting when a professor writes an article
and everyone disagrees with the article and they
want to ruin his career that's absurd right but i
also think that there are people who say something
hateful and violent and they should they shouldn't
they shouldn't say it and they should be stopped
from saying it um it shouldn't be propagated you
know if something is is truly violent and hateful
it doesn't need to be amplified i have a question
i have a question then just on that point then
um so my mentality is and my question to you is
often i quite enjoy hearing these things because
it tells me who this person really is like i
it really shows me the truth and can
i i really want to just take i always
here's a really extreme example right so i want to
take hitler as an example so i'm pleased that we
are able to know what he said and what he did and
we can hear his true opinions i just think it's so
important to hear this um because otherwise we
don't know how long that war could have gone on
for you know if things were if things you know if
we didn't hear if the opposing side didn't come in
you know if everything was done very quiet and
and you know i mean i know that was their goal
anyway in nazis to be done quite quietly um but in
those kind of cases i like i i'm glad that i know
where he stands i'm you know there are plenty of
um the the iranian um the iranian leader was his
exactly he's on twitter but i know where he stands
and i'm glad that i do um and now you're right
you're underground i'm glad that i know and
that jack hasn't de-platformed him yes taking
thinking he's de-platformed trump i know the truth
i really value that i agree and there's that's the
hard part is where you draw this line because you
want to hear these people's points of view because
you want to know where they stand and what they
believe and i think it's important to know that
but do you want it to then become a call to action
did you want him no i'm not call to actions no
hitler went on twitter and was trying to rally
people to do something awful you'd be against
it and you'd say cut this twitter i'm not saying
anybody is hitler but i'm saying there has to be
a line so someone has to draw the line so you you
do agree with me that there has to be policing so
that's the problem with the libertarians this
is hard it's hard you just disagree with where
they're policing it but not that they're policing
it i think i think i think i think it's just so
hard to draw that line and i'm very i'm very um
conscious of giving an inch and then taking a mile
i mean honestly if it was nowadays we disagree
i just think that i i'm i'm more jaded than you
are and i believe that there's just some bad
bad actors out there and you know what if if
less people spoke we'd be better off that's that's
that's my chicken i get that though let's everyone
just be quiet unless you have something
really good to say because you know don't
say something unless it's not what does it do if
it's not nice don't say it or whatever it wasn't
like i just wish the world were like that and i
get that it's not but i live in a delusional world
i live in a delusional you know fairyland with
unicorns and and and i want to live in a world
with unicorns and winklevi and why can't i just
live with that world so i think you know i think
my brothers have always described me as like a
muppet so when people ask me where politically
you are i'm like i don't think muppets have
politics i think other than that eagle on
the muppets all of the muppets kind of believe
that the world just get along and go along so i
i'm not i don't really have a political point
of view or a political horse in all of this
but i i do understand that listen de-platforming
people is dangerous and scary but there are also
people who should be d platforms i think i can
hold both those thoughts and listen these are
nuanced things you can't just say it on the
internet that's the other problem with the
internet i don't make any political statements on
twitter or anything like that because there's no
nuance on twitter anything you say is one second
and then flips it will piss off a lot of people
i think in a conversation it's great to
have these conversations and it's important
um but there's no nuance on the internet right
so that that may be tricky to ever say anything
and the limited characters are exactly part of
their um part of their sort of gameplay um so you
are so you've been at the party you've been at the
center of two of the biggest revolutions of the
decade not just the winkle vibe but you as well
of course we've been at the center and documenting
it so what can we expect um any more interesting
things coming up i mean i know you want to write
i've been chasing elon musk i've had my midnight
conversations i really would love to do and i know
there's been an elon musk biography which is great
and all that kind of stuff what i want to tell
if i could is really a thriller about the
specific things this battle he's fighting
against ai and to expand our consciousness and
to reach mars i think there's a great thriller
and movie to be told about this guy doing this
crazy thing and and succeeding so the way i would
approach the story would be specific like that
i lo i would love to write an elon musk book
um but i don't have landed you know for me i
need access to the main character or characters
around him enough to tell me the story i don't
want to just write another story around elon
i would love for him to just talk to me and i
think i could get there but that's that's what
i'm working on personally i have a big book
coming out i wrote a uh a serialized novella
for the boston globe over the summer which ran
it was called the mechanic and it was a da vinci
code style thriller going back to the american
revolution that was really fun and cool i wrote
it chapter would go up one night and i'd literally
write a chapter a day and it ran weeks and it was
very successful we had a huge readership so i
sold the movie to steven spielberg and amblin
and i'm writing the screenplay and then i'm
working on the book will be out next winter and
then a sequel the following year so that's i don't
have a big non-fiction book yet so i'm looking for
stories so people want to tweet to me send me a
story i'm always searching for a big enough story
to tell elon of course would be a great one but
whatever i i can find in that world but i i you
know tell you what's next or what you should
invest in next um i don't know great question
uh i think what's going on in biology is awesome i
wrote a book called woolly um which was all about
crispr technology and and uh but that's very hard
you know it's not it's not as easy to sell a book
as anything else so you know i think what's going
on with vaccines and covid is a is another sea
change in revolution i think these new vaccines
have come out are going to change the world
because you're going to have vaccines for cancer
you're going to have vaccines for alzheimer's
you're going to have vaccines for everything and
you know there's going to be people on both sides
of that too but um but this mrna technology is
really world-changing um but i don't know what's
next i'm always looking for the next big thing i
thought it was absolutely hilarious um when elon
musk replied to you just sort of saying i don't
have the time right i need to i'm trying to save
listen i don't want him to sit there and
write books i want him to change the world
for the better he's one of them you can just
follow him with your notepad and be like
i i think the winklevoss twins can tell elon that
i don't bother you too much you won't even know
i'm there i'm just like a fan i'm like a fanboy
i i have been criticized by a lot of journalists
that i fall in love with my main characters
and it's really true i write about someone
to me they're always larger than life even when
they're bad guys um like russian oligarchs or
whatever else i've written about i always kind of
want to tell their story in the best way possible
so i would say to elon musk i want to tell the
story that you want to tell i want to tell the
way you want to tell it um which is very different
than like a biography or something like that so
we'll see if i get to him um but uh you know
there's a lot of white whales out there so
i'll keep searching with my harpoon just last
question for you then um because you said you
know you're sort of living in this um this fantasy
world with your unicorns and the wink of eye and
all this stuff so elon musk has some pretty wild
um um opinions and one of them which i would love
one day to interview him about and just really
just like um just really want to scrutinise this
idea of his is that we're living in a simulation
yeah um so i i'm just so bothered by that um and
i really i i like i don't i have some that i have
some um like uh like what is it how do i put this
i have some ways i want to critique it basically
but what do you think do you think we're living in
a simulation i'm a big believer in the simulation
theory i have to say i'm not 100 convinced nine
percent convinced that word not that it matters
because i don't affect the stimulation i don't
think you can discover it and then not be in
it anymore but i do feel that looking at the
math of it that it seems very interesting to
me i mean if you look at the development of ai
and you look at the development of sort of how
computer games work and you look at you know
they're getting better and better and very
i just look at the video games that i play
today versus the video games i played when i
was in college you know that a hundred years
from now these video games are going to be
indistinguishable from reality and then the
idea that that these non-human players the
computer players are going to have their own
intelligence at some point it seems likely to me
anyways i know there are problems with that to me
so the idea that we're all in a simulation just it
kind of makes sense right i'm not saying you can
actually see it or notice it yeah you know it's
really interesting i was blown away by simulation
theory when i first fell into it years ago and uh
have done a lot of reading into it um it doesn't
change anything that's the weird thing but i i do
think that yes that's what's going on what do you
you don't think so or you don't want oh no no no
i'm cool with it like i'm i'm i'm an absolute i'm
i'm an absolute sci-fi freak i love all that stuff
i'm i'm down with that sure absolutely that's mine
my issue is but who says that we are the first
to get there that's what i'm saying like i agree
you know we were doing um it was it was just um
like the pongs and the ball and you know what i
mean yeah and then that now is about now we can't
really tell the difference so i get that we're
gonna get that and i also think that like humanity
this is probably you won't like this opinion but
humanity is just so inherently flawed that i don't
think we'll ever get to a point whereby we say
that's immoral so we shouldn't control them
definitely don't think that will happen
definitely think we'll get there but
who says that they're there before us
why are we not the first ones i mean we you know
you could right but if time is nearly infinite
then we couldn't be the first ones right because
over a vast amount of time the likelihood that
this moment in time is the first time that
happened gets smaller and smaller and smaller
i don't get that that's the better i get there's
an infinite point there's infinite points along
the timeline um so it goes on and on and on and
on and on and there are essentially potentially
infinite places this could be happening um so
there could be a planet a billion miles away
where they're making fake games also in another
planet a billion miles away so and then on each
planet there are nearly infinite simulations so
the odds that this is base one becomes smaller
and smaller and smaller the more chances there
are right so let's say on earth alone there are
a hundred million computers running simulations
right and then there's base reality so base
reality which is indistinguishable from the
simulations is now one of a hundred million so
the chance that we are in base reality becomes one
in a hundred million just on that one planet alone
so if you have a hundred million planets you can
do the math the chance that we're in base reality
just gets smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller right so eventually
the idea that we're based reality almost becomes
impossible because of the infinite possibilities
so that's the math behind simulation if you
run a simulation a million times the chance
that the first time you run it it becomes one
in a million um you know so that's that's the
way they look at it it gets confusing but the
other way well maybe this isn't even possible
so in fact there is no stimulation because it's
not even possible to make oh it's so possible
it gets really weird but i love this kind of
conversation i think it's better drunk or stoned
but i'm definitely great and of you know talking
about the simulation theory yeah yeah i agree
um okay so where can people find you what
are your final words um um that's the best
place to find me or you know yeah that's you
can you can you can message me on twitter i
mean you come to my twitter and then if you
have some great idea or whatever like that
but i'm always sort of tweeting about bitcoin
and then whatever else comes to mind and uh
yeah thanks so much i appreciate it um this
was a lot of fun thanks so much for coming
on it's been absolutely amazing um i had all those
questions so i'm so glad i got to talk to them and
talk to you about them so thank you so much
um and guys don't forget to tune in next week
thursday um 12 est back to normal time ben
thank you so much thank you awesome bye